hey 42 here there are many
terrifying animals on this planet but
on sheer looks alone you'll find it hard
to beat
the amplified otherwise known as whip
spiders or tailless whip scorpions
these are an ancient race of unholy
godless looking creatures
and i mean honestly just look at it
can you imagine lifting up your
bedsheets and finding that staring back
at you
a horrifying experience only exceeded by
finding harvey weinstein there instead
amblipaji have unsettlingly long legs
with unnatural
blood curdling proportions they wield
strains flesh ripping pincers and have a
face fit for something that has crawled
from the bowels of hell
to end life as we know it these
disgusting terrifying insects have been
lurking in dark
humid environments since the
carboniferous period
as if mother nature upon creating them
millions of years ago
took one look and thought god that's
hideous then left it where it was
and blippage eye don't just resemble a
monster they behave like one too
they are often subterranean always
nocturnal hiding in places where you'll
stumble upon
them unaware such as in leaf litter bark
or in small caves they use six of their
eight legs for walking
which they do sideways like a crab
the other two legs are used for foul
purposes
nobody can discern possibly obscene
gestures
they seize their unsuspecting prey in
their claws and then proceed to
violently
impale it and rip it to pieces typically
after descending on it from above
like a crossover between the spider-like
dexterity of ethan hunt
and the horrifying intentions of tom
cruise
no wait that already exists
although largely feeding on insects and
blipaj have been known to seek
out the fresh hot red blood of animal
life
when the opportunity strikes when they
mate
they violently spray sperm everywhere
and then lure females into their sticky
trap
again the harvey weinstein similarities
are endless
once the female has collected the sperm
she grows the young on her abdomen
then she carelessly lets them fall off
and
die of their own accord without even a
flutter of sympathy
our planet is home to incredible natural
phenomena
and life that is astonishing in its
beauty proud lions bellowing roars into
the savanna
the auroras cast dazzling arrays of
light into the sky
a huge flamboyance of flamingos dancing
in salt lakes
it's all too easy to get sucked in by
all this beauty and forget
that mother nature can be a dick and a
scary
and aggressive one of that because our
world also contains terrifying
disgusting animal life life that is
either repulsive to look at
or exquisitely designed to end your life
or both mosquitoes for instance get a
lot of press
for well slaughtering human beings in
droves
mosquito bites if you don't know result
in over 1 million human deaths each year
that's more than any other animal on the
planet including humans
but as terrifying as that is the
mosquito itself
isn't that scary it's just a flying
needle that makes a high-pitched buzzing
sound and can be deterred by some
store-bought repellent okay that is a
little scary
but it's hardly the stuff of horror
movies so
i hear you ask what does make the cut
well i want you to imagine a creature so
dangerous so
powerful that of all the animals in
africa
it's considered the deadliest this
animal has killed
more big game hunters than any other
animal
on the world's second largest continent
is it a man-eating lion
no a rampaging elephant no
it's this guy the african buffalo
and whilst it frankly looks like a dumb
cow
this is not an animal you want to take
lightly
because behind its brainless looking
exterior
is a being of pure unadulterated angst
and rage
that will stop at nothing until it has
turned you into human jelly
these massive animals often nicknamed
black deaf or widowmaker
each weigh over 900 kilograms and can
reach heights
of six feet tall that's one whole u.s
ton of bovine destruction that is
estimated to
go and kill over 200 people each year
gore if you don't know is when a horn is
driven directly into your abdomen
or smashed straight through your rib
cage or throat
and if the horns don't do the job they
can use their armored forehead to
pulverize you with such force
your organs will rupture straight out of
your body
they even attack men inside cars
still not impressed well they drink 40
liters of water a day
yeah now you're impressed free elements
make the african buffalo unbelievably
dangerous
the first is that they have a warrior
culture african buffalo males are
seasoned killers and brawlers
who in their quest for domination fight
for at least eight
years in their climb up the dominance
hierarchy
each male engages in complex rituals and
two did their fights that
improve upon its daring aggression
resilience ruthlessness
and combatability young males enter with
fresh strength and vitality and
older males defend their rank with
seasoned experience
it's the perfect melting pot for
creating the ultimate
bovine badass the second element is that
african buffalo males
often go rogue transitioning into an
almost
supernatural creature known as a dagger
boy
these are old warriors that have been
forced out by the herd by younger males
dagger boys form smaller groups of
hyper-aggressive easily provoked
killers and like all african buffalo
they practiced a combat strategy of
attack first ask questions later like a
bunch of yobs in a mcdonald's car park
at 2am
as a result these old warriors are an
exceptionally dangerous
elite splinter group of an already
lethal animal
the third element is that african
buffaloes are like characters from a
tarantino movie i don't mean they smoke
oversized pipes and wheeled samurai
swords
that would be funny but they are hungry
for vengeance
and they do not forget injustices
if they come into conflict with a human
they will often circle around him
pursue him and attempt to ambush and
kill him
even if it's been days after the initial
confrontation
wounded buffaloes are one of the most
aggressive animals on the planet
and upon the merest glimpse of you
they're likely to instantly charge you
driving their two tapering horns into
your stomach
disemboweling you and sending your
flailing body soaring into the sky
like the hopeless clown you are have you
ever wondered why we dive with great
white sharks
but not saltwater crocodiles well
it's because saltwater crocodiles have
one desire
above all to murder the ever-loving
out of you
they are what is known as a large and
opportunistic
hyper carnivorous apex predator
that's quite literally what it says on
their wikipedia page i challenge you to
find a more impressive animal
description
this means a few things about our friend
salty
it's the top dog the undisputed alpha
of its environment it's hyper aggressive
and
all-consuming in appetite for flesh
it takes whatever opportunity for murder
it can get
wherever it can get it saltwater
crocodiles will ambush their prey
striking from murky water
where it smashes its victims against a
waterbed drowns it or swallows it whole
in its enormous jaws because of how
unbelievably powerful large and vicious
they are
saltwater crocodiles are capable of
killing any other animal that it comes
across
this means sharks other crocodiles
bovine species and even humans
are all on the menu they can grow up to
seven meters in length
are coated in thick armored scales and
can weigh
up to 1 500 kilograms they swim three
times as fast as the fastest human
swimmers
so there is no escape they can spend so
long at sea they literally grow
barnacles like a pirate ship and for all
intents and purposes they are
a 240 million year living dinosaur
they haven't evolved since the beginning
of time mother nature
created a perfect death-dealing
lizard monstrosity whose ancestors quite
literally dragged tyrannosaurus rex
to a watery grave could you say the same
about your family tree
well maybe granddads can get quite
aggressive after a few whiskeys
a study by researchers at charles darwin
university found that out of the six
species of crocodile around the world
the saltwater crocodile was by far the
most aggressive
a good or rather gruesome example of
this was when a sedated
saltwater crocodile managed to rally
enough of its rage-fuelled neurons to
bite into a veteran's forearm
and tear it clean off a feat which in
itself is no surprise
saltwater crocodiles have the strongest
bite of any animal
on the planet reaching forces of sixteen
thousand 414
newtons they use this force to trap and
destroy their prey as they drag it into
the depths
and death roll the holy crap out of it
saltwater crocodiles have had numerous
fatal encounters with humans such as
when
in 1945 the british army drove japanese
soldiers into the swamplands of ramree
island
spending the night in the mangroves
countless japanese were killed
fought to be ripped two pieces by the
crocodiles lurking in the swamps
another example would be when a boat
accident in eastern india
led to 28 people falling into the water
and being eaten alive
now do you remember a few years ago when
there were reports of people reaching
for a banana at the supermarket
only to find the deadliest spider on
earth waiting for their unsuspecting
hand
well that spider was none other than the
brazilian wandering spider
the holder of the guinness world record
for the most venomous spider
in the world this hairy revolting
creature
bites hundreds of people each year
causing sweating severe burning nausea
hyperthermia
vertigo convulsions and much more
victims will only survive if they get
access to an anti-venom
this is one of the reasons its genus
name is derived from the greek
phenethria which literally means
murderous
or killer these spiders aside from
resembling the earthly avatar of
sin are incredibly dangerous because
well
they enjoy a stroll that's not a joke
that's genuinely the reason they walk
around all the time wandering from place
to place like the
anti-jesus sinking their satanic fangs
into anything that is unfortunate enough
to cross their path as they prefer to do
their wandering at night during the day
they seek out cover with their favorite
hiding places being your clothes
your shoes your house your car
or as mentioned before your banana
bunches
they're about as aggressive as they are
hairy
striking often and it will their venom
is even more powerful than the black
widow spider
and they're so badass and intimidating
they don't even need a web to call home
they just wander around killing things
like a nomadic street one even
wandered its way from south america to
england and left a man in hospital for
an entire week
could there possibly be any other animal
out there to rival this monster
well there is one
it turns out there is one animal so
violent
and so horrifying that it slaughters
every other animal
apex predator or not without mercy and
without reprieve
but it doesn't stop there unsatisfied
with its ability to slaughter everything
in its path
it even violently kills members of its
own species
with a rate of violence against its own
kind so high
that it's seven times higher than that
of any other animal
it is an animal neurologically hardwired
for violent rage fueled reactions
especially when you find them on college
campuses
with close to ninety percent of its most
violent members being male
and is in short the most violent animal
in the known universe perhaps this is
why it's also the most successful animal
in history i am of course talking about
us
you and me human beings neuroscientist r
douglas fields phd
sums up humanity's capacity for violence
compared to our animal kin
in his book why we snap our violence
operates far outside the bounds of any
other species
human beings kill anything slaughter is
a defining behavior of our species
we kill all other creatures and we kill
our own we kill our family members our
children
our parents our spouses our brothers and
sisters our cousins and in-laws
we kill strangers we kill people who are
different from us in appearance
beliefs race and social status
we kill ourselves in suicide we kill for
advantage
and for revenge we kill for
entertainment the roman colosseum
drive-by shootings bull fights hunting
and fishing
animal roadkill in an instantaneous
reflex for sport
we kill friends rivals co-workers and
classmates
children kill children in school and on
the playground
grandparents parents fathers mothers all
kill
and all of them are the targets of
killing
bloody hell douglas you sound like a
right bundle of laughs
i'm definitely not inviting you to a
dinner party
but dowa douglas does have a point
no other animal on the planet has the
capacity to instill fear in others
quite like you and me
thank you for watching if you enjoyed
this video then please consider
supporting me you can do that by either
joining the 42 club here on youtube by
clicking the join button below
or heading on over to patreon